[Music]
honest Tuesday night new urgency about
kovat 19 health experts warn a leap of
infections from the virus is coming
there has to be a shift in mindset the
warning to Canadians traveling abroad
and how Iran's deputy Health Minister
ignored his symptoms before admitting
he's ill new blockades and protests what
could finally settle this unrelenting
dispute a global news exclusive the
alleged scam preying on newcomers to
Canada raising questions about how
consultants are regulated and from
saving the day to having his own day it
was so cool a backup goalie netting well
deserved honors and newfound fame
global national with Donna freezing
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with new warnings about
the corona virus known as kovat 19 it
has begun to spread rapidly outside the
epicenter of China and countries are
bracing for the medical and economic
impact there's been a significant change
in tone from American health officials
who now warn of an unprecedented
potentially severe health challenge
globally and the World Health
Organization says the world is
unprepared for an almost inevitable leap
in infections folks this is a rapidly
escalating epidemic in different places
that we have got to tackle super fast to
prevent a pandemic the virus has spread
beyond China to the Middle East and
Europe the worst outbreaks right now are
in Iran where there are 95 officially
confirmed cases but experts believe many
more are undetected or unreported and in
Italy where at least 12 towns are under
quarantine there are more than 320
confirmed cases there and 11 deaths and
for the first time there are confirmed
cases in Switzerland Austria Croatia and
mainland Spain all of those involve
people who had been to Italy at least 38
countries have confirmed cases now and
the concern is as much about what is
unknown as is known about this virus we
know most people who get it survived but
it's still unclear how many people are
spreading it without having symptoms or
how many have symptoms and don't realize
they're infectious crystal gyum ancing
has our top story tonight
this is Iran's deputy Health Minister
sweating profusely during a news
conference on Monday downplaying kovat
19 he tested positive for the virus
hours later Iran is now confirming cases
of copán 19 in at least 13 provinces and
the country's health minister says the
disease will continue to spread more
than 80,000 people have been infected
globally China is still the epicenter
but new clusters are emerging Italy is
the worst-hit area in Europe they're the
11th death-related
dacovia 19 was a 76 year old woman in
the north museums bars and schools are
closed and police are restricting travel
in and out of 11 towns students from New
Brunswick are watching the situation
closely a group is headed to Rome and
southern Italy this week it's always
gonna be in the back of my head and I'm
just gonna try to keep clean and remind
people to wash our hands I understand
the worries that parents are expressing
so it's and I'm trying to allay those
fears as much as possible students from
three schools in northern England are in
isolation as a precaution some showed
flu-like symptoms after returning from
Italy we're just so much more connected
so you got to think it's gonna be here
tomorrow if you don't think that way
you're not going to be ready so first
thing is that mindset shift and the
thing you got to think is if it hits us
we're gonna stop it that containment
effort is happening in Spain a hotel
with roughly 1000 guests is locked down
two visitors have the virus with an
increasing number of cases outside of
China the International Olympic
Committee issued a warning dick pound
told The Associated Press that if kovat
19 isn't under control by late May the
2020 Tokyo Olympics could be canceled
Donna all right crystal commencing in
London thank you and an update now on
the Canadiens brought back to Canada
from Wuhan China Canada's chief public
health officer says the remaining 195
people under quarantine at CFB Trenton
have been released and if you're
planning to travel internationally
there's new advice tonight from the
Canadian government it had already said
to avoid non-essential travel to China
now Canadians are being told to take
precautions traveling to South Korea
Hong Kong Singapore and northern Italy
for those watching at home today I would
say before you book just make sure you
check that would be the best advice I
can give now because this thing is a
very dynamic situation it changed by the
hours and we will continue to have the
change and for the first time the
federal health minister says Canadians
should be prepared for their lives here
at home to be disrupted
by this virus my message to Canadians
today is to take it seriously obviously
we are working very closely there still
you know at this point is not that there
are not many cases in Canada but that
could change at any time given that
there is that there is such a
transmission globally and in the u.s.
public health officials are sounding a
loud warning the Centers for Disease
Control said this morning an outbreak in
that country is inevitable that the
country can't be hermetically sealed off
from the world that sent the Dow Jones
plunging there are fears what an
outbreak could do to the US economy and
later in the day the White House
economic adviser claimed the US as the
virus contained Jackson prosecco reports
on the US response with concern
spreading faster than coronavirus u.s.
President Donald Trump shrugged off
worries about the potential impact of
the disease very well under control in
our country the people are getting
better they're all getting better but
for the first time
US officials sounded the alarm warning
community spread of kovat 19 in the
United States appears inevitable I
understand this whole situation may seem
overwhelming and that disruption to
everyday life may be severe but these
are things that people need to start
thinking about now that stark difference
in messaging was repeated again on
Capitol Hill and I want to ask you is
our country ready where Trump
administration officials were grilled
about the country's preparedness in the
face of agency budget cuts and vacancies
in key roles so we do have in the
strategic national stockpile ventilators
we have masks we have in a prepared well
of course not the administration is
asking for two and a half billion
dollars to fund vaccine research and
stock up on supplies we currently have
30 million n95 respirators in the
strategic national stock I mean do we
need approximately 300 million one
immediate shortfall the Cova test kits
created by the CDC they're reportedly
faulty and have not been widely
distributed on Wall Street worried
gripped the markets for a second
straight day driving another steep dive
we would be very helpful and useful and
calm nerves if people had its real sense
that the administration is on top of
this
instead confusion as being sown far and
wide the coronaviruses is is the common
cold not just by the administration but
by far-right media commentators pushing
conspiracy theories and misinformation
the corona virus is being weaponized as
yet another element to bring down Donald
Trump officials in the US are echoing
those in Canada is describing the
current risk to the public as low they
also stress that could change on short
notice
which is why they're using such stark
terms in describing the need to prepare
Donna all right Jackson in Washington
thank you now to the other big story
tonight the blockades and protests
across this country in Vancouver police
moved in this afternoon to arrest people
blocking a major intersection at one of
the main entrances to the Port of
Vancouver at least five people were
arrested the group had blocked traffic
for almost 24 hours defying an
injunction they say they're supporting a
small group of with so itand hereditary
chiefs in northern BC who oppose a
natural gas pipeline running through
their territory what happens on what so
it and territory there will determine
how much longer the blockades across the
country continue and in Ontario and
Quebec new ones went up today a day
after police dismantled a blockade on a
rail line in Tyendinaga Ontario David
akin picks up the story at Tyendinaga to
stay concrete barriers and a line of
police officers keep a cien rail
crossing clear of protesters protesters
are nearby but there are no
confrontations and police say the
situation is peaceful but on Monday the
scene was more hectic as police forcibly
removed protesters and their barricade
those scenes sparked sympathy blockades
across Canada rail tracks used by go
trains in the Greater Toronto Area were
blocked disrupting travel for thousands
of commuters in Caledonia west of
Hamilton a protest shut Highway and rail
lines near the Six Nations reserve in
Quebec roads and rail lines were blocked
in Lennox Ville and in the Mohawk
communities of Conestoga and cogno a key
things may be escalating
on the side of the police so after what
happened with China [ __ ] yesterday
people are still quite angry but we're
we're controlled we're we're watching
and we're wait to see what'll happen
next
in response CP Rail obtained a court
injunction to clear all blockades in
Quebec a common theme among all these
protests is sympathy with the wet sewing
of northern BC and demands by with soin
hereditary Chiefs that the RCMP leave
their territory in the mean time cien
work crews have been up and down this
line doing regular maintenance and
survey work but see n itself cannot say
when these tracks and others around the
country will be safe to resume regular
passenger and freight service Donna okay
david aiken thanks the question of
whether the federal government and a
group of hereditary chiefs in with so it
and territory can come to an agreement
still remains they have said there are
conditions they want men including the
RCMP removing a remote outpost on a road
in northern BC my clica tour is
following the late-breaking development
Mike where are things at well Donna we
managed to speak with one of the wet
Soudan hereditary Chiefs who was on his
way to a meeting in Smithers BC with
other chiefs and the RCMP chief wass
said he's optimistic there will be a
withdrawal of the Mounties from his
territory which could pave the way for
the peaceful dismantling of blockades
that have popped up across the country
in the spirit of that good faith chief
wasps wouldn't say exactly what the plan
is for the RCMP to leave what's owed in
territory that cautious optimism is the
most positive chief wasps has been in
recent days it was echoed by the
minister of indigenous services
earlier today over the last few days
there has been some back-and-forth that
has been modestly positive and at the
same time Miller is preaching patience
to premiers as Tuesday France while ago
said Quebec provincial police are
working on a plan to dismantle the
barricade in Ghana [ __ ] a south of
Montreal I understand that that is not
easy it's not an easy situation but I
think at the same time we cannot afford
to continue for long having those major
losses on our economy we have now an
opportunity to engage with hereditary
leadership and make sure that that that
are back and forth or our discussions
are both aimed at resolving this in a
peaceful way and that's precisely what
we're gonna do
neither Miller or chief wass would say
if a nation Tunisian meeting is imminent
but a spokesperson for the indigenous
services minister said both he and the
minister of crown indigenous relations
carolyn bennett are ready to meet
whenever and wherever their hereditary
chiefs want Donna all right Mike look at
ER in Ottawa Thanks
coming up the changes planned to
Canada's law on medically assisted dying
in Ottawa plans are underway to update
legislation governing the right to die
the Liberal government has introduced a
bill aimed at easing some restrictions
on who is allowed to get medical
assistance to end their lives as Ross
Lord reports that's part of the law a
nova scotia woman spent her dying days
trying to change after signaling for
months the rules surrounding assisted
dying were going to change the
government is following through first
and foremost we have widened the
eligibility to access medical assistance
in dying one big change no longer will
an applicant need to be near death to
receive the service for those who are
deemed to be near death the government
wants to drop a requirement to wait 10
days after being approved before
receiving medical assistance in dying
the bill also reduces the number of
witnesses required from two to one and a
person would no longer need to give
consent a second time immediately before
receiving the procedure removing that
late stage consent was inspired by
Audrey Parker afflicted with terminal
breast cancer that spread to her brain
Parker chose to die with medical
assistance earlier than she wanted
rather than risk losing the capacity to
give last-minute consent days before her
death she made this video if I become
incompetent along the way I will lose
out on my choice of a beautiful peaceful
and best of all pain-free death no one
should have to face a decision like this
we used to love to kind of gather
together in her bed we'd call it the bed
of truth
Parker's friends say the so called
Audrey's amendment is better late than
never
we're happy that is what Audrey wished
but we are so delighted that it's going
to help Canadians and that was really
important to her to help others the
changes will make it harder for people
who are not near death to qualify but
some say overall these amendments will
make assisted dying more common I think
the number is going to increase it'll
it'll gradually level off more than
13,000 people have received medically
assisted deaths in Canada since it
became legal four years ago the
government says a parliamentary review
examining other issues in the law will
begin this summer
raus lord global news Dartmouth Nova
Scotia still ahead how a consultant with
numerous complaints against him was able
to keep working with newcomers to this
country
this is India's capital Delhi at least
13 people have died in violent riots the
clashes first broke out on Sunday
between protesters in favor of a
controversial new Indian citizenship law
and those against it the violence has
taken on religious overtones with Hindu
and Muslim groups fighting each other
police used tear gas and smoke grenades
but struggled to hold back the
demonstrators the new law makes it
easier for non-muslims from three
neighboring countries to gain Indian
citizenship well if you're a newcomer to
Canada and hoping to remain as a refugee
or immigrant you can hire an immigration
consultant there are more than 6,000 of
them in Canada each requires a license
to practice but as Jeff sample reports
one consultant allegedly scammed some
newcomers out of their savings the
Totoro veg family are Roma from Croatia
after coming to Canada in 2012 they
applied to remain here as refugees and
they met Artem the Jew kkuk a licensed
immigration consultant she says he
promised he could help
he has many connections so it's hundred
percent like we don't need to worry
about it
she says they paid him six thousand
dollars cash to represent them but when
they finally received an immigration
hearing she claims they discovered no
work had been done I was very angry and
basically he's stealing money he's a
thief she is taken from the desperate
people and she's far from the only one
making allegations over the last decade
working as an immigration consultant at
this office just outside of Toronto do
Chick received dozens of complaints and
a few years ago admitted to
misappropriating more than nine hundred
thousand dollars from a couple of
clients but if anyone thought that would
be enough to see his consultants license
revoked think again despite those
concerns did you kick was allowed to
continue working for three years much of
that time under the supervision of the
IC CRC the governing body for
immigration consultants and his alleged
misconduct continued so I would have
some serious questions around what
exactly was the nature that supervision
this immigration lawyer says
the Jew kicks is far from an isolated
case and proves the professions
regulatory body should not be allowed to
police itself the number of complaints
the number of victims are just
snowballing and and the stories we're
seeing every day are just horrific the
regulator says it's making changes to
toughen licensing requirements and
punishments for offenders the council
was set up to fail from day one by not
having that appropriate statutory
authority but the regulator has made
similar promises before and any changes
will come too late for this Hungarian
family they say they paid to juke ik
nearly a hundred thousand dollars but
claimed he failed to tell them about
their hearings and even withdrew their
refugee claim so he gave me a very hard
time me and my family the Lange family
contacted police who charged did you
kick with fraud and last month his
consultants license was revoked the
family meanwhile is now scheduled to be
deported we paid the price and I don't
want to more people we don't want more
victims Geoff sample Global News Toronto
next what life is like now for that
Zamboni driver turned hockey hero the
honours keep piling up for Canada's
newest sports star David Ayres
he's the Zamboni driver and emergency
backup goalie who suddenly found himself
on the ice with a Carolina Hurricanes
that moment and his unlikely rise to
fame is the stuff of movies as Mike
Armstrong explains he's still riding
high you gotta be tired man I'm
definitely tired today
this was his first interview of the day
after a Monday where David Ayers juggled
somewhere north of two dozen a standing
ovation from everybody between the Today
Show and radio hits Ayres says they were
almost overlapping can you do the splits
I can can you get back up after you do
what happened Saturday night isn't
supposed to happen Aires was the
emergency backup literally the backup to
the backup when he was forced into
service after two injuries and suited up
for the Carolina Hurricanes well the
Hurricanes broadcasters didn't like
their chances my heart breaks for this
hurricanes hockey club right now as it
turned out they didn't have to worry he
gave up two goals in the second shut the
door in the third and got a hero's
welcome after being named first star
[Applause]
ears is also a big enough star in the
sports world that he's being followed by
TMZ and getting his own jokes on
Laettner we got a great show for you
tonight and oh wow oh god I pulled my
hamstring I don't think I can finish the
my log now airs says Saturday's game was
a blur and it hasn't stopped since
Tuesday morning it was a press
conference in Raleigh at the home of the
Hurricanes I was screaming although the
best line may have been from his wife
describing the moment she saw Ayers hit
the ice and realized he was going into
the game I actually grabbed the guy who
I didn't know beside me and screamed
that's my husband
it definitely has been a row and there
is something Aires is trying to squeeze
into each interview the fact he had a
kidney transplant his mother 15 years
before this game gave him one of hers I
want to make sure that everyone else to
know is you know just because you have a
kidney transplant or something like that
it's not the end of the world IRA's
returns to his regular job Thursday and
then he'll be Saturday's Leafs Canucks
game as the emergency backup although
let's be honest he's been told that
before Mike Garbus our Global News
Montreal and that is global national for
this Tuesday I'm donor freezing tonight
Air Canada is Port Alberni BC we'd love
to see your Canada please email it to us
at viewers at global national comm
thanks for watching and hope to see you
here again tomorrow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]